il est à l'origine des vitraux de
beaucoup d'églises à la réunion dit
lefebvre maître verrier est au coeur
d'une exposition intitulée de l'ombre à
la lumière au musée historique de
villèle une rétrospective des créations
artistiques et des vitraux du maître
verrier réalisé à la réunion de 1965 à
2015 voisins les vizirs
c'est très bien présentés ou quoi et ça
me botterait en valeur mon travail guy
lefebvre est né et a grandi à madagascar
après avoir exercé divers emplois il
retrouvait développe ses passions
d'enfance dessin poterie et sculpture
avant de découvrir le travail du verre
musée vasa le lait des dessinateurs et
je vais travailler dans une entreprise
muniz et le faisait dès maintenant pour
les pharmacies
peuvent et un jour j'ai rencontré un
moine qui avait besoin que j'efface des
maquettes pour le faisais et vitraux
alors j'ai fait des maquettes poleman
pendant quelques années après ils ont dû
cesser leurs activités dans j'ai racheté
l'atelier les est devenu moi même
verrier depuis une quinzaine d'années
jean paul dupuy fumée qui lefebvre ce
film met en scène le travail en atelier
la restauration de vitraux mais aussi la
visite des églises de l'île où l'on peut
admirer toute la diversité des vitraux
nouvelle rencontre entre un cinéaste est
un maître verrier
le film qui est vie qui est diffusée
dans la chapelle est un film qui reprend
tous les vitraux que j'ai pu filmer à la
réunion donc c'est un film sur la
lumière un film sur la couleur un film
sur des formes abstraites des formes
figuratives et donc ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai pu apprécier au fil des
années avoir travaillé guy et je suis
quelqu'un un homme de l'image et du son
et donc j'ai eu un immense plaisir à
travailler à découvrir ce travail
le maître verrier s'éteint un métier
j'avais envie de filmer depuis très
longtemps
guy lefebvre a pour projet de sortir un
livre relatant ses oeuvres ses souvenirs
son métier un ouvrage qui devrait voir
le jour d'ici un an et qui sera
accompagné du dvd du film de jean paul
dupuy